bonjour claude bonjour avez vous
retrouvé dans cette matinale d'arreter
france alors on l'a vu les soudanais
sont toujours dans la rue est ce que la
situation peut dégénérer selon oui ça
fait trois ans que ça dure puisque les
les soudanais sont en situation
économique déplorable et en réalité il y
a trois ans ils s'étaient révoltés parce
que le prix du pain avait été multiplié
par trois l'inflation était supérieur à
200% par conséquent la pauvreté absolue
dans un pays qui par ailleurs est assez
riche puisqu'il ya des minerais ya même
des mines d'or et donc il avait obtenu
de l'armée à ce moment là en 2019
qu'elle dépose le président omar el
béchir qui était au pouvoir depuis une
trentaine d'années qui était lui-même
issu d'un coup d'état militaire
donc les militaires ont pris le pouvoir
mais évidemment ça n'a pas changé grand
chose parce que ce sont les militaires
d'avant qui existaient qui étaient déjà
les militaires qui commandaient l'armée
au moment de omar el béchir était le
dictateur de thor dans ce pays omar el
béchir qu'il avait recherché par la cour
pénale internationale
actuellement donc la situation n'a pas
fondamentalement changé et depuis on a
eu effectivement une tentative de 2,2 de
pouvoir duale avec l'armée contrôlant le
le conseil supérieur de la transition
et puis une tentative de formation de
gouvernement civil lequel gouvernement
civil a été déposée par un nouveau coup
d'état militaire il ya deux mois et puis
quand on a demandé au général barran ce
qu'il avait fait du premier ministre
qu'il avait mis en prison il a dit non
non il est chez moi il va très bien et
en effet il a mis quatre semaines à
négocier un accord avec lui cet accord
est un accord politique qui permet au
premier ministre de revenir mais aux
conditions du général en question et ces
conditions sont évidemment que les
élections qui devaient avoir lieu
bientôt sont reportées de deux ans et
que les militaires pour être candidat
aux élections donc la situation n'a pas
fondamentalement changé et la population
naturellement restent dans la rue et
demandent en fait un changement de
système et est ce que ce gouvernement de
transition
est ce qu'il peut espérer voir émerger
un nouveau gouvernement ben oui je pense
que finalement compte tenu de la
situation politique
on n'a pas vraiment le choix il va
falloir que l'armée joue un rôle dans la
transition et le premier ministre qui
est revenu qui a conclu un accord avec
les militaires et chargées de former un
gouvernement de technocrates lui même
est un technocrate puisqu'il a été
fonctionnaire international et je pense
que pour avoir l'aide du fmi de la
banque mondiale des etats-unis de
l'union européenne qui est nécessaire
dans la situation de ce pays il faut en
effet qu' un gouvernement de techniciens
qui rassure mais il faut aussi que les
militaires se mettre un peu en retrait
et comme le la junte a de bons rapports
avec
le maréchal 6,6 avec les égyptiens qui
sont quand même très proche des
soudanais je crois que l'egypte pourrait
peut-être jouer un rôle apaisant dans
cette situation extrêmement difficile
alors justement quel rôle doit jouer la
communauté internationale selon
la communauté internationale a suspendu
son aide évidemment puisqu'ils les
militaires ont refait un coup d'état et
il ya peu de temps
le fmi la banque mondiale ont suspendu
leur aide
l'union africaine pour sa part a
suspendu le soudan de toute
participation
je crois qu'il faut faire attention à ce
genre de mesure parce qu'il faut pas
sanctionner la population
effectivement essayé d'agir sur les
militaires pour qu'il laisse
véritablement le la possibilité à un
gouvernement civil de prendre des
décisions mais des décisions pour
réformer l'économie or 85 % des
ressources budgétaires sont préemptés ou
contrôlées par l'armée peu ou prou une
grande partie des entreprises notamment
dans le domaine minier est contrôlé par
l'armée et c'est cela qu'il faut
réformer et c'est cela effectivement que
les militaires ne veulent pas perdre
c'est ce cet intérêt économique sur
lesquels ils veulent garder la main en
prolongeant la transition de deux ans et
en se présentant aux élections dans deux
ans donc là dessus il y aura sans doute
un bras de fer et il faut que la
communauté internationale puisse faire
pression sur les militaires et donner
les moyens au gouvernement civil de
faire les réformes économiques qui
s'imposent merci beaucoup claude pour
votre éclairage une nouvelle fois
l'édito diplo de claude blanchemaison
c'est tous les mardis matin dans la
matinale de relater france